Tom Sachs: Avoid camera movement.
Film Courage: Especially with a DSLR like
a T2i?
Tom Sachs: Any camera, whether it’s a DSLR
or a red or any camera.
Camera movement is a privilege.
It’s not a right.
It’s an indulgence…you should do as little
work as you can…an idea shouldn’t be anymore…Einstein
said this….and [pauses to think] I’m going
to screw this up…everything should be as
simple as possible but no more so.
In other words, use a tracking shot.
Zoom in but only to an effect or a better
example may be omit unnecessary words [referring
to Authors Strunk and White].
A sculpture should be as small as it can be
to communicate the idea.
That might mean in needs to be the size of
a building in some cases but it could fit
in the palm of your hand.
Everything else is just hubris and ego.
QUESTION FOR THE VIEWERS: Do you agree?
What are your thoughts on camera movement?